you don't often hear music like this in
the southern Indian city of Bangalore
heavy metal bands sued Accra are causing
quite a stir at the vapor Club fans go
wild for the band
I don't feel my neck so I don't know man
this was the most kick-ass thing I've
seen thanks for the whole crew to bring
sadaqa down to India we love it you know
wunderbar
sooo docker one of the few international
bands to embark on a tour of India they
played in six Indian cities this summer
traveling the length of the country from
north to south the tour included
performances in Kolkata and Mumbai both
highly populated and congested
it's a d'autres third trip to India it's
certainly special for a band like in
this case sued Accra to come to India
people here really appreciated I always
compare it to the German metal scene in
the 90s when American bands didn't
always include Germany on their tour
plan that's why I think it's exciting
and that's why we enjoy playing abroad
so much suit dock were one of Germany's
most successful metal groups and often
play at international festivals in 2009
they performed at the Bakken metal
festival in northern Germany our cardio
Sun tonic is the band's frontman his
first name spelled backwards reads sued
Accra the band have released 11 albums
in their 14-year career
they often fuse death metal with full
kill events like in the song doubt 2059
back in India no it's been growing fast
in the last few years the metal scene
here is still quite small but the fans
are all the more passionate for it
you see it when you look at the crowd
and their eyes are all lit up they're so
passionate and hungry they're just
really into it Yama's broken
sadaqa have another important reason for
being in India there the headline act at
the vac and metal battle events a
spin-off of the annual German festival
bands for more than 40 countries take
part
they all perform with such passions but
one of the things a lot of bands lack is
their own distinctive sound they tend to
imitate their idols from America or
Europe which i think is a bit of a shame
I think it would be much cooler if
Indian bands would incorporate some
traditional music and include
instruments like the sitar for instance
a few bands do but it's not really a big
thing but as I said they do it with
passion and that's what music is all
about if the atmosphere in the vapor
Club is anything to go by heavy metal
can look forward to a very bright future
in India